alors que les masques sont devenu un
accessoire quotidien pour chacun d'entre
nous aujourd'hui certains prétendent
pourtant que les masques chirurgicaux
que nous portons tous ne sont pas
suffisamment efficaces
le haut conseil nous recommande de ne
plus utiliser le masque artisanale qu'on
a fabriqué chez soi s'il est prouvé que
les masques ffp2 sont quant à eux
beaucoup plus efficace ils sont aussi
plus rare est beaucoup plus cher c'est
pourquoi une autre solution semble être
adoptée par de plus en plus de personnes
non stéphane le double masque il s'agit
de porter un masque chirurgical
classique et de le recouvrir d'un masque
en tissu une compression qui permettrait
d'éviter le maximum de projection
contaminantes comme le confirme le
docteur américain dr fauci une astuce
que de plus en plus de personnalités
publiques semblent suivre comme le
nouveau président américain joe biden
alors selon vous faut-il porter de
masque pour être en sécurité porter des
masques pour être en sécurité on va
venir également tout de suite sur les
annonces de jean castex ce soir et on
n'a pas trahi peloux également qui est
avec nous en face time merci patrick
d'être là merci mon chéri merci beaucoup
alors on a des nouvelles alors là bruno
fuchs pharmaciens qui venait pour nous
voir aussi pour les deux masques pour
être en sécurité
on va d'abord parlé de ce qu'a dit jean
castex
l'objectif c'est de ne par confiner
maintien du couvre-feu centres
commerciaux trop grands fermés recours
effectif au télétravail renforcer plus
de sanctions pour ceux qui ne respectent
pas les règles patrick pelloux votre
réaction
voilà aux nouvelles nouvelles mesures
prises par le premier ministre si c'est
des mesures qui permettent d'éviter un
un confinement strict
cc c'est possible et c'est envisageable
je pense qu'ils essayent là encore ce
que je suis j'ai eu plaisir de venir
vous dire la dernière fois on essaye de
limiter cette pente qui est lentement
ascendante de reprise de l'épidémie
voici sa donc donc pour l'instant il
essaie de privilégier
mine de rien en corse qui peut rester
ouverts est-ce qui peut encore sauver
l'économie
mine de rien je trouve que c'est pas une
si mauvaise nouvelle voilà on donne ans
et encore j'ai l'impression que c'est
encore une dernière chance avant leur
confinement c'est vraiment une dernière
chance d'y demandons à tous les français
de faire un effort de respecter
règle vraiment de d'être de plus en plus
vigilants pour essayer d'éviter ce
confinement qu'on a vu dans la plupart
des autres pays patrick peu loin oui
c'est ça c'est à dire qu'en fait là on
joue une partie qui est qu'elle très
complexe c'est à dire que d'une part il
faut être sur le front de l'épidémie et
pouvoir arriver à freiner le plus
possible cette épidémie et puis de
l'autre
évidemment la partie sur sur les vaccins
qui est absolument crucial
il ya deux partis qui sont joués et là
ce qu'on essaye coûte que coûte de
limiter le plus là on est déjà à 3300
malades de duos covit qui sont dans les
lits de réanimation on a une capacité de
lits de réanimation de 5500 en france
donc voyez ça monte ça monte de manière
assez importante et rapidement alors aux
deux masques est ce que c'est ça fait
partie peut-être des choses qu'il faudra
faire pour éviter en confinement parce
que c'est ce qu'on a entendu aujourd'hui
par exemple joe biden porterie deux
masques et l'un sur l'autre
on voudrait nous le dire tout de suite
on passe aux tweets à la dernière partie
deux masses pour être en sécurité c'est
n'importe quoi ou c'est vrai nom c'est
vrai de masse c'est toujours mieux que
toi oui bon d'accord le départ logique
avoir une meilleure protection
sachant qu'au début je vous ai amené des
les masques utiles les ffp2 oui ça c'est
des vrais masse et des masques dont la
filtration est très très importante à 98
99 % le médecin pourra vous le dire on
n'a pas besoin de masse qui ont reçu le
nom celui-là c'est exactement ce qu'il
faut aujourd'hui on est on s'est
débrouillé pour en avoir fait savoir
qu'au début les pharmaciens vendée ce
type de max on a été interdit de les
vendre
pourquoi parce qu' il fallait laisser
pour le corps médical
d'accord mais ça et cela cela il faut
remettre 2 alors il ya plusieurs types
de ces masses s'appelle des masques
chirurgicaux il ya les type 1 type deux
types de r donc les types de r oui ce
sont les plus résistants et n'est plus
où ça nous en empêche justement les
gouttelettes de traverser des